يستطيع الحفاظ على التوازن الدقيق في
تزويد الطاقه والخدمات الاخرى ما يصعب
عليها الامور اكثر فاكثر المعاناه في
الحرب لا تقتصر على طرف دون الاخر القوه
الروسيه هي الاخرى تتكبد خسائر فادحه
لانها تهاجم مستخدمه طرقا معروفه للجيش
الاوكراني
تطورات على الارض تسير عكس الجهود
المبذوله خاصه تلك التي تقوم بها الصين
دول غربيه طالبت شيجينغ بالضغط على بوتين
للتراجع مقابل رفض واضح من البيت الابيض
لمساع الصين جهود تصطدم بما يحدث على ارض
المعركه
فبسبب الدعم المتزايد من الغرب للقوه
الاوكرانيه خاصه من الولايات المتحده
واصرار موسكو على تحقيق ما تريد على الارض
ورقه بيكين للتسويه قد تتمزق قبل ان يتم
توقيعها بين طرفي الصراع بلال الوجداني
العربيه